can you say what your favorite and least
favorite things are about President
Trump and President Biden one at a time
so maybe one thing that you can say
super positive about Trump and one thing
super negative about Trump okay so the
the super positive thing about Trump is
that because he has no preconceived
views that are establishmentarian he's
sometimes willing to go out of the box
and do things that haven't been tried
before and sometimes that works I mean
the best example being the entire
foreign policy establishment telling him
that he couldn't get a middle eastern
deal done unless he centered the
Palestinian Israeli conflict and instead
he just went right around that and ended
up cutting a bunch of Peace deals in the
Middle East or moving the emcee in
Jerusalem right sometimes he does stuff
and it's really out of the box and it
actually works and that's that's kind of
awesome in politics and and neat to see
the downside of trump is that he has no
capacity to to to use any sort of
uh there's no there's no filter between
brain and mouth well whatever happens in
his brain is the thing that comes out of
his mouth I know a lot of people find
that charming and wonderful and from
time to and it is very funny um but I
don't think that that it is a a
particularly excellent personal quality
in a person who has as much
responsibility as president Trump has I
think he says a lot of damaging and bad
things uh on Twitter I think that he
um seems you know consumed in some ways
by his own grievances which is why I've
seen him focusing in on Election 2020 so
much and I think that that is very
negative about President Trump so I'm
very grateful to president Trump as a
conservative for many of the things that
he did I think that a lot of his
personality issues are are pretty severe
what about Joe Biden so I I think that
the thing that I like most about Joe
bides
um I will say that Biden two things one
Biden seems to be a very good father
by all available by all available
evidence right there are a lot of people
who are put out you know kind of tape of
him talking to Hunter and Hunter's
having trouble with drugs or whatever
and I keep listening to tape and
thinking
he seems like a really good dad like the
stuff that he's saying to his son is
stuff that God forbid if that were
happening with my kid I'd be saying to
my kid uh and so you know you can't help
but feel for the guys had an incredibly
difficult
go of it with his with his first wife
and the death of of members of his
family and then bow dying I mean like
that kind of stuff obviously is deeply
sympathetic and his his you know he
seems like a deeply sympathetic father
um as as far as his politics he seems
like a slap on the back you know kind of
guy and I don't mind that I think that's
that's nice so far as it goes it's sort
of an old school politics where things
are done with handshake and personal
relationships and the thing I don't like
about him is I think sometimes that's
really not genuine I think that that
sometimes
um you know I think that's his personal
tendency but I think sometimes he allows
the the prevailing winds of his party to
carry him to incredibly radical places
and then he just doubles down on the
radicalism in some pretty disingenuous
ways and and there I would cite the the
Independence Day speech with or the
Independence Hall speech which I thought
was truly one of the worst species I've
seen a president give so you don't think
he's trying to be a unifier in general
not at all I mean I I that's that's what
he was elected to do he was elected to
do two things not be alive and be a
unifier those were the two things and
like and when I say not be alive I don't
mean like physically dead
this is where the snark comes in but he
but what I do mean is that he is he was
elected to not be particularly activist
basically the Mandate was don't be Trump
be saying don't be Trump calm everything
down and instead he got in he's like
what if we spend seven trillion dollars
what if we what if we pull out of
Afghanistan without any sort of plan
what if I start labeling all of my
political enemies enemies of the
Republic what what if I start
bringing Dylan Mulvaney to the White
House and talking about how it is a
moral sin to prevent the general
mutilation of minors I mean like this
kind of stuff is very radical stuff and
this is not a president who has pursued
a unifying agenda which is why his
approval rating sank from 60 when he
entered office to low 40s or high 30s
today unlike president Trump who never
had a high approval rating right Trump
came into office and he had like a 45
approval rating and when he left office
he had about a 43 approval rating and
bounced around between 45 and 37 pretty
much his entire presidency Biden went
from being a very popular guy coming in
to a very unpopular guy right now and if
if you're Joe Biden you should be
looking in the mirror and wondering
exactly why yeah do you think that
pulling out a form of Afghanistan could
be flipped as a pro for Biden in terms
of he actually did it I think it's going
to be almost impossible I think the
American people are incredibly
inconsistent about their own views on
foreign policy
in other words we like to be
isolationist until the time comes time
for us to be defeated and humiliated uh
when when that happens we tend not to
like it very much